[Music]
here we go again
PlayStation have revealed the free games
for PlayStation Plus subscribers for the
month of july 2019 the following games
are available from the first Tuesday of
the month so that is the second of July
I have a feeling you may not like this
month's offerings are you ready I think
I'm ready let's do this first up is a
football classic and before the comments
section is filled up with soccer vs.
football arguments let's call it by name
Pro Evolution Soccer 2019 go back around
15 years and Pro Evo was regarded the
best football sim around but that mantle
was taken by EA's FIFA since then Konami
have worked hard to improve PES which
now boasts more real world licensed
players and teams than ever before and
twelve leagues from around the world the
new feature called magic moments is the
selling point here with many traits of
footballers recreated like the no-look
pass all intersection skills you know
stuff like that without a doubt the best
thing about PES games is the master
League immersing yourself in the
day-to-day running of a club from
preseason tournament to epic Cup Finals
this mode will take off your life if you
let it fall player couch co-op is great
when the labs come round I'll take it
online and get humiliated by a 19 year
old who's never been outside in his life
Pro Evolution Soccer 2019 is up to date
until the next game arrives in August is
that enough time to convert you over
from FIFA or couldn't you care less
about football and soccer please let me
know in the comments ok game two this
will either make you think about
cancelling your PS Plus or you'll see
the 90s nostalgia dripping through this
is horizon chase turbo back in the days
of arcade cabinets there was a racing
game known as outrun which at the time
was one of the greatest games available
horizon chase turbo attempts to cash in
on that success with a modern recreation
using an art style akin to the Super
Nintendo and soundtrack 2 it may not
seem this way but there's more than
meets the eye there's a tour mode and I
have to admit the speed here is mighty
impressive with up to 4 mates racing
there could be some fun to be had here
but come on help me out guys I can't
polish this turd if you like racing
games that
better than they look try horizon chase
turbo so there it is how are you feeling
if you need to vent do so in the
comments are not both the ones that you
agree with I'm a little underwhelmed
this month I have to admit but I know
these games will make somebody happy is
that you right I'm going back to play
board lands - which is still available
to download on PS + until July the 2nd
it's bloody great and so a sonic mania
from last month so less let's forget
about this month and move forward I'm
Adam from PlayStation granade it's been
a pleasure well sort of
I'll see you next time
[Music]